children deserve like
detailed detailed stop motion
as uh kirsten laporte
our animation director put it at a q a
it actually takes so much more effort to
make things be invisible and effortless
she's just so
one of a kind incredible people think it
takes a long time
but like
it really takes a long time
like i would say i would say a good
reference for people to think about is
is like you know on a on an ideal day
you might get you know five maybe 10
seconds of footage and that's like 10
seconds like that's a killer shoot day
you know one animator getting a 10
second shot i think that's a good sort
of frame of reference for uh for how
labor intensive it is but also how much
it sort of pays off and you get the
magic of of the real objects to play
this character who is heavily improvised
and then pair it with a process that at
once has to be filled with life like you
have to be completely open and also
detail-oriented down to the tiniest
minutia in order to make marcel seem
like his emotions aren't just coming out
of his mouth but that they're in his
body that's a real honor it's like a
real honor to to pair up to have one of
my performances paired with that type of
art because
there is so much dedication to that
intention and
that feels really good and it's actually
something we've tried for marcel like in
general you know with our children's
books all of the the images in those
books are oil paintings done by an oil
painter named amy lind it's the same
pairing that like i think the thinking
behind that has always been that adults
enjoy marcel and and children do too one
thing people don't often give to
children is like rich
art and like we were like children
deserve oil paintings they should just
have marcel in them you know children
deserve like
detailed detailed stop motion
[Music]
dean was very involved in the whole
process i mean we
from the beginning like from the time
the audio play was ready and all the
voices were recorded we worked really
closely together storyboarding
everything so it was literally just us
on zoom basically back and forth just
planning out every single shot
meticulously in board form so we had
really our kind of whole road map of of
what to do once we came to the studio to
actually shoot i mean i think your job
as a director is to prepare like a mad
person and be a total perfectionist in
the preparation and then when you're
actually on set be willing to throw
everything out the window and just be um
an opportunist i mean i was both on set
for the live-action shoot really
involved in every shot making sure we're
sort of timing out okay how far are we
moving marcel
you know like in this very you know like
in five seconds how how far would he
move and i had kind of like a little
puppet on a stick that i would
approximate and sort of like bop it
along
um and then once we got to
the stop motion shoot then we sort of
translated that to that stage and dean
was with me on every single stage we
would pow-wow before each shot and sort
of like act out like a lot of times like
i would play marcel he would play connie
um and we would we would just kind of
play off of each other and figure out
okay what is the performance that we're
really going for here uh before we even
go in to talk to the animators and then
once we game planned and got on the same
page we would go in and we would usually
just act it out for the animators
sometimes also making a reference video
for them just so they have as much
information as possible going into their
shot because it takes them you know a
whole day sometimes two days to do an
entire shot so you want to avoid retakes
as much as possible because you don't
want someone redoing like two days of
work where they've been like
painstakingly laboring over a tiny
puppet for you know so many hours when
dean is dedicated to an aesthetic he
does it all the way he is the first
true artist that i feel like i've ever
met besides my own parents and then to
see his work replicated by this entire
team
you know it was incredible that there
was just still a connection even with
all of these other people there they all
know who lives here they all like they
all care even in the board phase like we
had a lot of fun coming up with like
okay what does um one that comes to mind
is like you know what what is connie's
little meal like that we cut to and it's
like okay it's a quarter with like a
generic goldfish cracker and like a
little piece of like dust on top you
know for garnish like those little
things that was there was there were
tons of them tons of them like uh and
just finding what those little
jokey moments are that play with scale
was i think one of the most fun parts of
the process also like down the line once
we once it came time to design marcel's
family members like the extended
community shells we brought in another
friend of ours this woman akko and we
all kind of sat together and went
shopping to all these like
crazy electronic stores and like really
specific niche places all over la like
this shell store that was amazing and we
just like collected tons of stuff and
then laid it out on the table we just
spent hours like designing little
characters out of the actual props um
and i think that's you know something
that you wouldn't be able to necessarily
just figure out off the top of your head
as you're even boarding like we really
tried to be as hands-on as possible in
finding those actual real objects you
know in the spirit of marcel he's an
actual real show that's one of the fun
parts about doing it in motion too like
that's what makes this movie so much
like tied to this specific medium like
it it really can't be done in cg like i
feel like the thing that makes it truly
real and
and using these actual real objects like
that that is sort of at the heart of um
stop motion and working with with actual
things
you have to surrender yourself to the
current moment and this movie was a
exercise in that because the whole point
was to try to make it feel
authentically spontaneous and
documentary but obviously when you're
telling a story with a stop-motion
live-action hybrid that is uh has all
these things going on you you can't it's
it's a an illusion that that was in any
way spontaneous there are really no
films that are shot like this i mean
with the exception of like monkey bone a
long time ago even that isn't a great
comp because it's kind of like a bigger
puppet so we really have nothing to go
off of and how to sort of figure out how
do we shoot this movie how do we make it
work and how do we make it really really
naturalistic and feel like oh marcel was
just we turned a video camera on and we
just captured him so that was you know
definitely a challenge there was a
moment where we were considering okay
maybe we actually shoot it in the house
and have the animators like down on the
floor you know crouching like with the
puppets maybe we control all the
lighting in the entire house and like
flag off all the windows so that was
something we considered but in the end i
think that would be a little too
physically grueling for those animators
because houses aren't built like
stop-motion sets you know stop-motion
sets are built very particularly so you
can get underneath them you can like tie
things down really get access to
everything you need to on that miniature
stage
so ultimately we ended up going that
direction but a lot of other tests of
crazy camera heads and recording you
know the camera's motion and translating
that to the stage there were so many
things we played with and then
ultimately we figured okay we have to
shoot this twice and just sort of comp
it in a more traditional way i felt very
committed to trying to make this as much
like a real documentary as possible and
i never seen a quote unquote
mockumentary that actually took its
subject seriously and treated them with
dignity
uh and so it was kind of always a
question of well how do we how do we
solve these problems how does marcel get
you know to his stockpile or whatever uh
how does he get from one room to another
quickly while also you know trying to
keep it within the realm of possibility
because with an animated character you
know you could make him fly or whatever
you're not bound by those live-action
rules but it so i think we're constantly
trying to gut check ourselves against
what a real documentary would look like
and do in movies for children there will
be sorrow there will be
loneliness or fear
um but this is a movie for everyone and
i think
one thing that i try to do not just as
an artist but as a person is to soothe
the child that remains inside of me and
i've also learned that now as a parent
that through your art and through your
behavior with other people you can start
to kind of like if you want to sort of
re-parent yourself
and
a lot of that has to do with allowing
for a big variety of emotions to be held
inside of even the smallest individual
and
you know for it's like it would be easy
to make marcel like just be cute but
instead i think what dean and i really
wanted to do and we were like well when
it comes down to it when we're alone as
dean and jenny what what makes us feel
good what makes us feel satiated is
putting as many emotions as possible
into one place